hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game that was played in the
professional chess association
intel gram free in paris in 1995 and
it's a rapid tournament this is the
second round of the tournament vladimir
kramnik faces vasily manchuk
uh and uh well as today's kramnik's
birthday a lot of you have requested a
game uh by kramnik
and i thought this was a fitting one as
it features uh well
sort of a present uh from vassell and
you know i thought it was a good idea
since today was his birthday
and it's quite a present to to to get as
you'll see
uh in the in the video so without
further ado let's check it out it's a
pretty uh standard opening nothing
you know crazy happening but it features
a very cool twist so here we have knight
to f3
uh kramnik starts off with already
opening we have knight f6
c4 and the g6 now preparing bishop g7
castles and so on we have knight to c3
uh d5 striking in the center captures
captures in the now
e4 attacking the knight with knight
captures on c3
b captures bishop to g7 and now uh
finally white plays d4 move and we
basically transpose into the main line
of the groomfield defense
uh asking uh what do you what do you
want to do here uh so here
the standard idea is just keep
challenging the center that's how this
is played we have c5 challenging the
center
and also there's the problem of the rook
on a1 so
kramnik wants to eliminate this uh
problem right away so he goes rook to b1
now black will have to be careful
with the development of the light square
bishop otherwise he's going to lose the
b7 pawn
so castles and now bishop to e2 kramnik
now ready to castle we have knight to c6
ending now d5 now challenging this
knight
chasing it away uh into the corner on a5
and um
here bishop captures on c3 is what
vassal played and it's uh
it was a very very popular move but
nowadays knight the e5 is um
kind of a safer approach and people are
avoiding bishop captures on c3
because it tends to get very very
complicated and the lines of attack are
very very clear for white as you'll see
in the game
uh but la vas will not want a back down
from a challenge he accepted bishop
captures on c3 with
check uh we have bishop to d2 he trades
off
the dark square bishops captures
captures in the now knight to a5 and
this is uh
often the destiny of this knight on a5
in the groomfield defense it will either
remain here for the rest of the game
uh sometimes that's good for black most
often it's not but
if it's able to rejoin uh the the other
pieces then black will have a great game
but let's see what happens here
uh kramnik starts now by uh attacking on
the king's side he plays
h4 he wants to play h5 capture here open
up the h file
play queen to h6 and check made the
black king that's sort of a
uh you know the dumbed down variation of
the idea uh black will of course try
everything to prevent this
vassal goes bishop to g4 and now h5
uh and now capturing this with the
bishop although possible
isn't recommended and no you don't
capture the bishop right away i know
that's what you guys want to do but you
play
g4 and then black is just lost because
now you either lose a piece or you
capture this in queen h6 you're getting
checkmated
so instead after h5 we have bishop
captures on f3
g captures on f3 uh kind of ruining
black's king side but
a white king said but why doesn't matter
the white king will be
very safe on e1 or maybe even on f1 or
maybe even on g2
we'll see what happens so here uh the
queen needs a way to
help out with the king side so here we
have e5 you don't have to worry about
alpha
because black will definitely enjoy
trading queens
uh so h captures on g6 now the queen is
ready to join the attack we have f
captures now both the rook and the queen
will be able to keep an eye on the h7
pawn
and now d6 and this is all very very
standard stuff this is nothing new
uh even back then a queen d5 check now
is coming
and there are a lot of threats here you
would not believe how many threats
there are and i'm just going to show you
some of them here for example if black
isn't careful let's say black plays
something like rook to e8
you immediately uh can forfeit because
now rook captures on b7 and that's it
so now you can see that there's simply
too much going on here if knight
captures some
if you don't capture then you simply
cannot defend the h7 pawn this pawn is
just a monster here
so you'd have to capture but now queen
d5 check and
uh whatever you do simply doesn't matter
if king to h8
we're just going to play queen to f7 and
there is no defending checkmate
if you try something else for example
after this check you could try king to
f8
uh but uh it's still not going to do all
that much good bishop c4 and now
either queen f7 checkmate or queen here
check me the pawn is still covering the
e7 square
and aside from h8 and f8 you could go to
g
g7 but now we just pick this up with
check and after the king moves we just
pick this up and that's it
you're either getting checkmated here or
here or here
you're getting checkmated somewhere so
d6 is a deadly move
and uh vassal needs to be careful so you
do not want to allow rook captures on b7
vassal prevents this by playing b6
now the knight is welcome to rejoin the
game and that's uh
basically what we are always wondering
will the a5 knight uh
you know come back uh we have queen to
d5 with
check king the g7 and now queen captures
an e5 so
like you've seen you can't really defend
this pawn with any means otherwise you
get that variation that we've just shown
and now queen to f6 uh just offering a
trade uh
and saying okay i would very much enjoy
trading queens here
but uh kramnik goes back we have queen
to h2 now threatening queen captures an
h7
and uh well even if you play something
like rook to h8 queen coming to h6 check
will cause a lot of problems for
uh for black so here we have h5 now you
don't have to worry about the h7 pawn
anymore
but now how do you continue the attack
with white and this is very important
here
uh problem is if you try something like
e5 and it definitely that does make
sense you have two connected past pawns
problem is queen f5 attacks the rook and
now
after for example rook to d1 knight c6
comes back into the game this knife is
coming to d4 will block the past pawn
or rather rook's defense of the pass
pawn and then when the knight comes here
you're going to have a lot of pressure
on the f3 pawn so here black definitely
goes back into the game and it's all
because this knight rejoins the game
that's how powerful this knight is
so here uh kramnik plays the absolute
best rook to d1
uh there are some ideas where you could
try with queen to g3 but rook the d1 is
just
very straightforward and you will enjoy
this and now what do you play here
uh well here uh black is actually
perfectly fine black can continue
playing this
game in a lot of ways just bringing the
knights to c6 makes sense you want to
bring the knight to d4 and then you're
fine you don't have to worry about those
pawns
uh you can block off the the rook
defense of the pawn also you keep an eye
on the e5
square so you don't have to worry about
e5 and then you you will start bringing
your other rook into the game
and so on uh for example queen g3 can
come
now yes you're threatening this but now
knight comes here and it's a very very
uh tricky position uh for example rook
captures you're just going to play rook
to h8
you're perfectly fine here uh however
after this rook the d1 move
vassel did not play knight to c6 but now
we reach the position
from the birthday gift that i mentioned
uh vassell plays knight to c4 and we
reach the position from the thumbnail
seems like a free knight it's not a free
knight really because queen to c3 check
will win back the piece
uh but it poses some other problems so
here
bishop captures on c4 was played queen
to c3 checked by vassal king f1
queen captures in c4 again winning the
spawn uh
piece with check and now you have to go
to g2 you have to defend the pawn with
the king you do not want to allow rook
captures here because then your
entire position just crumbles so king g2
and now
rook a to d8 and it seems like vassal
was able to bring all of his pieces into
the game
but there is a one problem here kramnik
plays queen to e5 with
check we have king to g8 and now we
reached a position where
as usual you guys will pause the video
and win this game
for kramnik in great style while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those who were able to do it
congratulations on finding this
beautiful beautiful move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's
rook to d5 uh if you for some reason
decided to play queen to g3 this also
works but
um it works because okay now you attack
this pawn and if we defended with the
queen now you're just going to play
rook captures on h5 and then well the
position will just be unplayable rook
and come to h1 you can play rook g5 go
after this pawn
a lot of ideas here and if you don't
defend with queen to e6 if you defend
with the king let's say king h7
now you play rook to d5 with the with a
very similar idea
because now after rook to d5 there's
simply no defense against the rook
captures here uh whatever you play it
doesn't really matter we're just gonna
capture here with check
captures and this will be checkmate so
while queen to g3
is playable uh rook the d rook to d5 is
just a bit more straightforward so
congratulations if you found either of
those two moves
uh so here what do you play uh well now
the queen no longer has
access to the king side and will have
it will be impossible to be of any
assistance to the black king
so here rook the f7 now the rook can
help out with the defense here but also
you can maybe get your king to f8
but now comes rook the h3 now bringing
the other rook into the attack here
so rook d to d7 gaining control of the
of the seventh rank
now rook to g3 defend uh attacking the
g6 pawn we rook the g7 by vassal
and here uh vladimir played a queen to
e6 check
and he was in this position on all 29
that vastly vancouver resigned in the
game and a brilliant victory for
vladimir kramnik in round two
of this of this paris grand prix rabbit
tournament because
now it doesn't matter where you go with
the king this rook can always
move and open up a discovery towards the
white queen so if you go h8 or h7
we're just gonna pick up this pawn and
after captures we're gonna win the queen
and that's it there's no playing this uh
same same could be set of king to f8 if
you go king to f8
we can win the queen like this but then
we have to give up the rook this is even
more straightforward
so we don't even have to do this now
this is a threat there's no
there is no defense against this so it's
uh
really really pointless uh so another
thing you could do after queen to e6
check you could block
check with this rook but here kramnik
would just say okay d7 thank you for my
second queen and now you resign there's
no move black and play here
so really a a crazy crazy game and it
all came down to this moment after
kramnik played rook to d1
where a vassal uh and it you know it's
basically his signature move
vassel said that you know the hardest
move to find is with the knight back
and here he went uh forward with the
knight and it simply
you know was not a good move uh but he
tried it made sense uh but the position
was simply
uh unplayable uh but it's also a nice uh
nice game to know you know
from theoretical point of view because
it's uh it's just a standard groomfield
and you can see that all all of these uh
ideas are possible that you can give up
the h pawn then you can give up the g
pawn as well black has to be very
careful about the b7 pawn so b6 has to
be played
and like we mentioned the knight
remained on a5 for the rest of the game
and
oh not for the rest of the game but uh
for a very long time and it
didn't retreat the c6 but c4 and that's
it uh just uh
just a you know a crushing win by uh
former world champion vladimir kraunic
who if you're wondering turned 45 today
so yeah there you have it
and the kramnik crushed the entire
tournament but it was a knockout
tournament and then
in the finals uh he uh was knocked out
by gary kasparov
uh but yeah other than that william
tournament ended brilliant victory
against vaseline chuck so
i hope you guys enjoyed that and uh yeah
i i don't always get a chance you know
you guys often um i mentioned that okay
today's uh
we have this birthday this birthday this
birthday uh then
uh you know uh uh this death anniversary
then this uh yeah and
it's really a lot so i don't manage to
cover all of them
but from time to time i will cover them
and now now was the
well one such time so once again hope
you guys enjoyed it congratulations to
everyone who found either of the two
moves you are an excellent player
i would like to thank alexander
williamson derek king jorge campos
david traynor and kevin stormer for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day